bonjour et bienvenue sur des gones al tv
émission spéciale rui lopes des sig où
la sortie de son livre entièrement
traduit en français en notation
algébrique ses droits que c'est la
première fois livre de l'invention
libéral et art du jeu d'échecs publié la
première fois en 15 100 1561 1561 alors
c'est une époque il faut savoir où
l'espagne domine le monde économique et
maritime avec la grande armada la fin de
cette grande armada
on est sous philippe ii d'espagne quand
henri lopes publie son livre philippe de
l'espagne c'est le fils du grand charles
quint charles quint qui a été le plus
grand monarque d'europe qui a réuni
plusieurs plusieurs royaumes et finit 2
donc son héritier hérite d'une espace
surpuissante qui a tracé le chemin vers
l'amérique qui a conquis et bien
l'amérique centrale l'amérique du sud et
qui donc que ramène beaucoup beaucoup de
richesses en europe et qui se retrouvent
donc extrêmement puissante et rue lopez
est le meilleur joueur du monde il ne
saura des faits que environ 14 ans je
crois c'est en 15 175 c'est ça face à
leonardo da coutry le l'italien donc
quinze ans après l'édition 14 ans après
l'édition de ce livre ce livre fait 457
pages 457 pages d'histoire 457 pages de
fondation du jeu d'échec puisque bien
entendu on va retrouver l'origine de la
partie espagnole mais aussi beaucoup de
choses c'est ce qu'on va voir tout de
suite alors rapport courir un petit peu
quelques pages de ce livre on pourra pas
ravit évidemment bien entendu tout voir
c'est impossible
donc on y va rui lopez de ségou l'a donc
libre nommément sur libéral hier du jeu
d'échecs libro de l'alimentation libéral
est actée dès lors que dresse alors il
faut savoir que l'invention libéral ça
signifie en fait
l'invention d'un art libéral en fait
c'est à dire que les arts libéraux était
saoul ans quitte l'antiquité
chez les romains en fait les
les les les matières qui était enseigné
notamment les mathématiques l'astronomie
ce genre de choix voilà donc cessé un
sens très différent du terme libéral
qu'on peut voir qu'on peut connaître
aujourd'hui voilà bon tout ça est
expliqué dans le livre il ya aussi pas
loin de 450 note de bas de page dans ce
dans ce livre voilà quelques quelques
éléments alors le sommaire à consommer
rien que le sommaire fait pas loin de 16
pages vous imaginez 16 flash de somer
vous voyez comme le livre est dense et
riche
alors il est séparé en quatre livres
alors tout d'abord il ya ici quand une
recommandation de l'officiel que j'ai
que j'ai traduit entièrement parce que
je me suis basé sur l'original c'est lui
directement de l'espagnol en commun
nations du représentant du roi qui est
très intéressante en termes économiques
de voir ce qu'il est ce qui est dit là
c'est tout à fait intéressant ce qu'on y
parle de la vente de livres etc
des choses très intéressantes l'épître
de rue lopez dont la lettre
l'introduction de riopelle très
intéressante aussi donc traduite aussi
et donc le livre ou un c'est une reprise
des travaux de moralité du jeu d'échecs
de jacobus de ses solistes jacques de
cessole dominique un italien vers 1300 à
1400 qui écrit un livre de deux
fondations de d'explication de la forme
des pièces de leur marche de la marche
des pièces de l'histoire du jeu de ses
origines
pourquoi parce que avant avant lui avant
jacques de cessole le jeu d'échecs était
interdit par l'église comme on dit
l'élise interdisez tous les jeux à cause
des problèmes de des paris de vie ce
qu'ils avaient sur les jeux notamment un
jeu de hasard mais justement on a
expliqué que jeu d'échecs était pas un
jeu de hasard donc finalement les
guisards est revenu sur sa position et
pour finalement permettre la pratique du
jeu et bien dominicain jacques de
cessole a écrit un traité de moralité
voilà un traité de moralité que rue
lopez reprendre ce qui est très
intéressant avec ce livre c'est qu'il
reprend
c'est pas la seule chose qui reprend
vous allez voir des éléments antérieurs
qui qui fondent le jeu donc ce traité
vraiment un traité de consolidation et
de fondations du jeu à cette époque
seuls l'espagne et l'italie vraiment
jouer aux échecs
très très peu en france voire pas du
tout très très peu en angleterre très
peu en allemagne voire pas du tout c'est
la spa ni l'italie il faut savoir que
c'est l'espagne qui sort de sept siècles
d'occupation parlée par les arabes de 2
700 environ afin fin 14 192 je crois
tout simplement 489 c'est la prise de
grenade par les rois catholiques
espagnols c'est le dernier bastion bord
donc sept siècles d'occupation ou les
mots en implanter un petit peu le jeu
d'échecs
enfin même un petit peu beaucoup et donc
c'est de là que la pratique finalement
il a plu c'est là que la pratique il a
plu est la plus forte en espagne et
aussi est aussi en italie donc le livre
ou un ça reprend ces éléments de jacobus
et solis alors on va voir qu'il ya quand
même un beau y regarder on va arriver
jusqu'à 28 28 chapitres voilà j'avais 28
chapitres pour ce premier livre il
reprend ces éléments bien sûr aussi les
commente alors à noter le chapitre 27
chapitres 27 ici qui est très long en
fait il n'apparaît pas ici mais en fait
il est très long et c'est là où les
règles et conseils de rue lopes son sont
établies sur le jeu d'échec quand les
règles du jeu sont concentrés ici et
avant on a quand même ici la forme et la
marche des pièces qui sont expliquées et
justifiées
c'est très intéressant pour ça en termes
historiques alors je passe livres 2
on rentre vraiment à partir libre de
livres 3 livres cas dans le jeu d'échecs
avec cette fois donc vraiment ouverture
technique de jeu explications le livre 2
c rue l'opel le cru 2 rue lopez comment
jouer tel est l ouverture on va voir
c'est très intéressant il faut savoir
aussi qu'à l'époque donc le roi ne rock
pas il n'ya pas le rock le rock quand
même se couche de pièces à la fois un
roi et tours mais le rose saute et donc
tout le traité de rue lopez leroy sow
ceci dit c'est quand même référence
rock qui existe quand même à l'époque
pour savoir mais uniquement comme il le
dit dans certains endroits d'italie
voilà donc pas dans toute l'italie
certaines parties d'italie arue le sait
parce qu'il a fait des voyages en italie
en tant que prêtre puisque rio ps est
prêtre il va notamment assisté à
l'élection du pape donc donc il en parle
d'ailleurs dans le livre c'est très
intéressant à suivre il va en 15 261 à
rome pour l'élection du pape et il va
ici là-bas rencontrer les meilleurs
joueurs italiens qui va qu'il va tous
écrasés à ce moment là ce qui va
réitérer d'ailleurs plus tard avant
finalement de perdre face à leonardo da
contre il est 14 ans plus tard quatorze
ans après l'édition du livre dans un
tournoi organisé à la cour du roi à
madrid donc cette cette façon que le roi
a de sauter donc de bouger de deux cases
où il veut et y compris en sautant par
dessus ces pièces un peu comme un
cavalier mais il peut le faire comme un
fou aussi donc il peut sauter de deux
cases comme un fou c'est le seul à
pouvoir faire ça et bien change un petit
peu la nature la nature du jeu et
notamment l'évaluation des positions
d'ailleurs change
alors voilà livres 2 donc ces ouvertures
avec ce fameux roi qui qui saute alors
regardez là aussi c'est quand même assez
long est ce une partie assez dense
jusqu'à 29 chapitre voilà ensuite on a
le livre iii niveau 3 alors là on passe
d'autres choses
c'est vraiment très intéressant
puisqu'il va reprendre là aussi quelque
chose d'autre le livre de damiano alors
damiano portugais qui précède louis
lopez il est au début 16e siècle dans
les années 15 115 120 15 130 par là son
livre sort à rome et en 15e 112 où je
crois d'ailleurs à vérifier la date
exacte c'est écrit dans le livre je vais
pas en tête ici damiano sort son livre à
rome d'où qu'ils soient portugais parce
qu'il a émigré
et migrer à rome il sort en italien et
ce livre fait autorité apparemment
puisque rieupet ce sens dans
l'obligation de reprendre ce livre
damiano qui s'en douter le seul libre
qui est citée par les joueurs parce que
c'est le seul libre un peu théorique qui
reprend douze chapitres à c'est un petit
livre comme il le dit henri lopes librio
il appelle les briauds ce qui veut dire
petit libre livré comme s'il voulait
wibree qu ils utilisent soit les jolis
coups soient les religions
donc c'est très intéressant en terme
espagnol se livre donc reprend quelques
quelques ouvertures expliquer notamment
le fameux granby de damian où l'on verra
un exemple tout à l'heure donc oui au
père reprend le lire au damier quasiment
intégralement il reprend les
applications web et sur l'idée et
simplifie aussi pour que ce soit lisible
alors avec la notation et les brics est
encore plus simplifié et il va bien sûr
les critiques et les commenter et les
enrichir donc c'est très intéressant en
termes historiques puisqu'on se retrouve
avec jacques de ses sols et damian ou
trois livres dans un en fait finalement
et enfin alors ce livre iii qui est
quand même important puisqu'il va faire
jusqu'à 20 va chapitre 21 mn de regarder
24 chapitres 24 chapitres
c'est une partie très importante et on
fait le livre iv très intéressant les
parties avantage car les parties m'ont
donné par exemple une pièce l'adversaire
davantage ou un pion ou l' avantage de
jouer deux coups d'un coup ce genre
davantage qu'on donnait aux joueurs
moins forts pour lui donner des chances
alors faut savoir comme le ru lopez il
existe l'expliquent pardon même à
l'époque il expliqué en détail on joue
quand même on joue de l'argent il ya des
enjeux sur les partis et donc parfois
pour intéresser la partie on va donner
un avantage pour que les joueurs
acceptent de jouer en espérant bien sûr
les défaire et prendre et prendre la
somme gagnée au passage donc libre cas
très intéressant mais plus court
une quinzaine de chapitres là jusqu'au
chapitre 15 mois on va voir le thé dans
quelques exemples de ces contenus sur
les sur les trois livres qui suivent qui
suivent sur les quatre livres
d'abord sur le livre 1 donc c'est à dire
la partie origines du jeu et notamment
lors chapitre 27 donc je vous ai parlé
un petit peu qui reprend toutes les
règles toutes les règles et la façon de
2 mais sûr de pouvoir jouer aux échecs
et aussi les conseils de rue lopez parti
je crois qu'il y avait plus d'une
vingtaine de règles est aussi une
vingtaine de conseil tout ça dans ce
chapitre 27 qui est le plus gros de tous
les chapitres du vieux livres 1 est qui
et qui est vraiment un chapitre très
très dense
alors oui la page partir de la ligne 3
mais nous des buts et on finit la page
précédente ce qui veut dire qu'une
partie de la victoire et de déconcerter
l'ennemi avant que de se battre alors
les notes de bas de page ici le
déconcerté vient du terme espagnol tout
le bas alors faut savoir que dans le
livre il ya plus de quatre cents 400
notes de bas de pages dont 457 pages de
livres et plus de 400 note beaucoup de
termes espagnol que j'ai repris pour
pour les curieux et notamment les
hispanisants kivu qui auraient voulu
avoir quelques références des termes
j'ai mis parce que parfois moi j'ai
choisi une traduction non pour le
traduire autrement bien entendu alors le
7ème conseil et que le joueur essaie
d'amener son ennemi à être le plus
fatigué et le plus affligés que possible
et c'est quand même très amusé au
conseil ça parce qu en me mettant ainsi
la pression la force de son imagination
se tarira et cela lui fera faire des
erreurs ce qui sera le contraire si la
compréhension et l'imagination facile
qui sont la cause permettant l'invention
de beaucoup de merveilleuses suite et la
découverte de bons coups
parce que comme nous l'avons dit plus
haut une partie la victoire et de
perturber l'ennemi voyez comme c'est
quand même joli comme conseils ça
voilà c'est quand même très beau de voir
ce type de conseils quand même qui est
très pratique très pragmatique on est
loin du jeu et sur la fatigue de
l'adversaire et si on sur comment le
sait tirer profit comme ça de las de sa
forme
l'a8 le huitième ou la huitième règles
huitième conseil 8e règles et que celui
qui veut devenir un bon joueur et qui
souhaite remporter la victoire sur ses
ennemis fasse en sorte de toujours les
attaquer avec ses troupes
bien organisée et unie en ne se
dispersant pas en eux dispersant pas
d'un côté des pions et de l'autre les
pièces s'en séparer les pions les uns
des autres autant que possible parce que
s'ils jouent de manière dispersée ses
ennemis le ferons facilement échoué
comme le dit vers aetius dans le livre
iii titre 15
magis expedite août concert tim cook ne
vous passez du latin ici de beaucoup de
latin alors c'est jacobus de ces souli
souci qui citait du latin mais là on est
sur les règles établies par par willot
ps lui-même is it beaucoup d'auteurs
d'auteurs italiens ce qui veut dire
qu'il est meilleur à mon fils traduit
quand même aussi heureusement ce qui
veut dire qu'il est meilleur qu'il
convient mieux que ceux qui veulent
obtenir la victoire se battent en rangs
serrés collés les uns contre les autres
pourrait-on dire afin qu'ils puissent
s'avantager et cd sans s'écarter au loin
car si l'escadron est beaucoup trop
séparés ou amaigri pourrait-on dire en
étant prestement et impétueusement à
salies par leurs adversaires il serait
brisée et démantibulé les ennemis
entrant parmi eux pas mieux ensuite il
ne pourrait plus y avoir aucune solution
du fait qu'ils ne puissent pas se réunir
pour les renforcer et les défendre comme
le dit le même veris youth et c'est
encore une citation latine
alors voyez c'est quand même un très
très imagé beaucoup de références aux
auteurs anciens et antiques latin
notamment pour expliquer des termes de
bataille des termes un petit peu
guerrier
comment le jeu d'échecs permet d'avoir
des allégories comme ça sur sur la
notion de
de bataille alors un autre on est plus
loin et si on n'est pas 148 notre
conseil aux règles de jeu je trouve ça
intéressant à vous vous montrez comme
exemple alors nous l'avons dit mme touré
un cavalier ne peuvent pas a gagné la
partie contre une tour si celui qui a la
tour s'est joué ça ça fait référence à
la page précédente
donc il nous explique quand même peu
touret et cavaliers on ne peut pas
gagner contre une tour et ce qui est dit
dans ces deux règles précédentes donc
n'est pas contre celle qui les précèdent
mais parce qu'il faut prendre en compte
mais parce qu'ils parce qu'il faut
prendre en compte qu'il faut le tenter
quand celui qui le temps ne peut pas
perdre qui s'aventurent à essayer de
gagner alors il ya une note de bas de
page
ici avec un échiquier alors il enrichit
pied et rajouter parce que dans
l'original
ok c'est que du texte donc c'est très
très lourd à lire très très tous les
coûts notamment ses du texte c'est pas
du tout de la notation et des briques et
donc c'est long et difficile à dire mais
ici comme ça ça simplifie on voit une
position ici simplement il nous explique
que si au bon moment ici avec touré
cavalli ici on peut prendre le pion le
pion f5 avec avec le cavalier ici voilà
il se calait on peut prendre le pion f5
à noter que la tour ne peut pas venir à
f7 pour clouer le cavalier puisque
viendrait faire un échec en d6 la tour f
7 serait perdu on peut prendre un f-16
et après la prise du pire on prend de la
tour et on se retrouve aitor et de pions
contre tours et cavaliers ce que nous
explique louis lopez essayer de tenter
ça parce que lui de toute façon et uri
car il pourra pas gagner mais vous vous
avez deux pions maintenant et donc si
vous sacrifiez lecavalier contre deux
pions vous pouvez tenter de gagner
voyez des conseils très pratiques très
intéressant à étudier
effectivement et touré deux pions contre
trois cavaliers vous risquez pas de
perdre vous ne risquez que de gagner
vous pouvez gagner très difficile à
gagner mais en tout cas vous avez des
chances de gain donc l'adversaire en a
plus voilà tout ceci nous le dit notez
bien de le faire au bon moment et selon
où se trouvera votre propre voix parce
qu'ils pourraient se trouvait enfermée
dans un endroit tel qui ne conviendrait
pas de le faire pour ne pas perdre la
partie
quand même fait attention fait ce
sacrifice mais vérifier quand même que
vous serez pas mates derrière parce que
montreront est mal placée oui c'est
quand même très à la fois simple
pratique donc c'est même intéressant sur
beaucoup de thèmes c'est très
intéressant même pour un débutant
d'étudier le jeu d'échecs en commençant
par la rue lopez parce que il me donnait
des explications simples sur des sur des
choses qui peuvent paraître simples à
des joueurs aguerris et qui sont pas
simples pour un débutant qui sont pas
évidents à forcément évidente à
comprendre du premier coup 19e règles
que tout joueur soit averti qu'une
tourelle cavaliers à eux seuls ne
peuvent pas gagné la partie contre une
tour donc ni selon l'usagé en italie ni
selon celui de l'espagne selon celui
d'espagne ni d'aucun autre endroit je ne
dis pas seulement qu'on ne peut pas
donner maths mais ni liquide est
différent bat quand celui qui a la tour
s'est joué de sorte que vous devez faire
en sorte d'amener votre or on entend que
possible au centre de l'échiquier
attaquant le roi adverse avec des échecs
et s'il se couvrit son cavalier de le
tenir cloud et de manière à ce qu'il ne
puisse se servir ni de lui ni du roi là
aussi note de bas de page et un
échiquier qui suivent pour illustrer ce
propos qui est aussi intéressante
voilà pour vous montrer jusqu'où vont
les conseils règle générale du jeu que
nous propose donc rue lopes alors on
poursuit avec cette fois on rentre
vraiment dans le livre avec le chapitre
26 une autre façon d'organiser
d'organiser le jeu voilà on va voir ici
ici c'est cette partie cette partie de
rue lopes ici ils commencent par eux 4
200 f 4 voilà c'est un gambit droit donc
voyez il nous propose un environnement
très intéressant issifou c5
et il y aura une ou dix fausses et c'est
un petit commentaire qu'on voit ici un
petit commentaire sur ces souks ou parce
que les blancs nous aurons pas prendre
en scène car les noirs de nos riches etc
par damas quatre échecs il gagnera la
partie effectivement si on prend ici un
simple et noir regard des joues dame h4
échec au roi ou valleroy si au jour de
deux vidéos on est des rockets alors là
ici s'il n'y a pas de rock mais le roi
ne pourra plus hautes et c'est la même
rems île où il pourra plus sauter et le
problème c'est que si rod à mach 4
échecs si on fait g3 la dame ensuite
prendre et le bureau kde puisqu'on a
pris le plus sain qui prendrait elle
prendrait ou quatre échecs et la tour
est perdu
voilà c'est pour ça qu'ils nous
expliquent que les noirs gagnerait la
partie si les blancs près 900
voilà donc c'est pour ça que les noirs
n'ont pas peur de jouer tout de suite
fous ces cinq est donc là les blancs
poursuivre par alors hop ici qu'à liège
3 des 6 puis en 30 sec
et là il nous propose
ah oui alors sur piot prendre 5 voilà
puis on prend 1,5 cavaler prendre 5 est
maintenant d'un match 4 alors ça semble
être un peu la même et c'est pas tout à
fait pareil puisque évidemment là il
toujours pareil si on joue barroso va se
prendre un mais deux échecs et puis le
roi est en balade et puis si on joue g3
d'emprunt 4 avec la tour qui permet
c'est pas la même chose parce que les
les blancs vont quand même ici jouer
j'ai trois pour ne pas être mat pour
éviter de se faire mater puisque suroît
eux deux il ya même maths en fait ont
regardé ici la position si on joue à eux
deux ont fait même pas d'un mais de deux
échecs ont fait d'un reprend eu quatre
échecs et mat puisque le roi peut pas à
venir en f2 à cause du fou donc on suit
matez donc on n'a pas le choix faut
jouer les 3 et c'est pas très grave
est ce qu'on fait à près d'1 3 4 qui a
l'air de gagner la tour c'est le cas
mais simplement fait dame eu deux dents
prend hatcher est maintenant en europe
cavalli g6 échec à la découverte de la
dame
donc c'est très intéressant voilà il
nous le dit d'ailleurs échec et la
découverte une nous dire où lopes est
ici simplement
sur cavaliers 7 eh bien on peut prendre
la fuite
les noirs vous quand même issifou h3 qui
rajoute du cloud âge sur sur les blancs
et dior et nous explique lennon avons
échangé dame est fou puis saute aurons
avec le roi alors voilà il se feront en
j'ai vite ils vont faire ils ont le
droit de jouer roi g8
voyez davantage du sceau du roi c'est
quand même plus puissant que le rock
certes même si la tour est pas là
l'europe quand même bouger deux cases il
s'auto avec leurs ong huit gagnants
lecavalier voilà effectivement là le
fameux cavaliers qui a pris une pièce
mais qui en fait est pris lui même au
piège et donc comme les noirs ont gagné
une tournette ils ont ils ont gagné une
tour contre cavaliers qui vont devoir
rendre donc c'est pas bon pour eux et
donc ils gagnent là la partie moyenne
donc c'est très intéressant alors il
nous dit aussi quand même une variante
on va une variante ici nous propose 4
pouces et 4 c'est à dire ici donc de
prendre de jouer plus tout le coup fou
c4 etc en mer sans doute mieux dames 7
et la kabylie j5 attaque le pion f7 nous
propose ça et qu'est ce qui se passe là
dessus kvh 6 pour les noirs dames 1 h 5
on rajoute de la pression sur le pion f7
il a infligé quatre ans l'émission les
noirs peuvent venir ans j'ai quatre
attaquants la dame et la foux prend à
vii et oui on profite du fait que si le
cac et prend et bien le fou ici j'ai 4
ans n'est plus n'est plus défendu voilà
et il nous explique que certains
considèrent comme étant un bon coup donc
là il nous montre pas forcément les
meilleurs coups il nous explique en quoi
tel ou tel
début de partie donne tel ou tel type de
position il faut bien un faux bien
suivre à sa méthode d'explication il
nous donne y compris des mauvaises suite
ils cherchent pas nous montrer les
meilleurs coups nous cherchons à nous
expliquer les pièges qui a dans
l'ouverture
donc les noirs prennent avec f7 de la
dame
pas bête puisque comme ça le cavalier
continue de protéger g4 lecavalier
protège de dames et 7 et la dame h5 est
attaquée serre si les blancs près de la
dame et 7 ils vont perdre la dame h5
c'est ce que font les blancs a
simplement les noirs prennent la dame
hcl et après cavaliers prend ensuite il
nous explique le cavalier perdu là
encore le câble est perdu on warocqué
faf on va sauter avec le roi en fuite
ce cavalier perdu et regarder les pièces
on a un deux trois quatre pièces contre
deux pièces mineurs et donc tout retour
il ya une tour contre 2 pièces et il
nous explique que c'est mieux le
cavalier perdu ainsi les noirs ont gagné
un fou un cavalier contre une tour est
un pion il reste avec un meilleur jeu
car ils ont une pièce de plus voyez donc
c'est quand même très bien vu de la part
de rue lopez en 1761 il nous explique
pourquoi cette variante est pas si bonne
que ça alors une autre possibilité ici
c'est que ici ils nous proposent aussi
damage 4 et simplement avec les noix on
prend le pion f4 selon selon lui et il
nous explique puis les noirs joueront f6
attaquant le club et j'essaye donc les
noirs ensuite joueront f6 attaquant le
cavalier g5 et ainsi pourront bien
organiser leur jeu et ainsi pour bien
organiser leur jeu alors à noter ici
comprendre f4 aussi la dame maintenant
attaque le 4 on par exemple sur
cavaliers prend f7 peut-être que les
noirs peuvent prendre 4 avec échec et on
va le roi
or on attend quand même embêter puisque
le fou j'ai quatre emplois devenir
dérobé obligé de venir en f1 et ça a
l'air quand même un tout petit peu
délicat puisqu'il ya d'hommes prend ses
quatre échecs au roi et on reprendrait
le quartier derrière donc c'est très bon
pour les polinois voilà donc il nous
explique c'est ce début de partie voyez
dans ce livre
voilà une des parties de ruines au ps
alors on va voir maintenant une autre
partie en cette fois on va sauter dans
le livre numéro 3 donc c'est la partie
où j'expliquais où il traite du traité
de damiano damiani
donc c'est ce fameux portugais qui avait
écrit ce livre avec le fameux gambie de
damiano et c'est un peu ce qu'on va voir
là si ce fameux temps vide damiers noir
il va l'expliquer plusieurs fois
notamment ce passage il dit s'est
proposé par damiano il fera un chapitre
spécial pour expliquer que ce comment
selon lui seul henri lopes il faut jouer
donc il est moi il sait par un petit peu
comment damien nous propose des choses
et comment selon lui il faut il faut
jouer alors eu quatre ou cinq cavaliers
f3 à leurs commentaires attaque le pion
sec pour le protéger les noirs peuvent
faire trois choses alors attention la
ciel commentaires de damiano que rue
lopez a repris d'accord donc il faut
bien comprendre ça on le comprend en
lisant le livre un essai explique ici en
titres de chapitres proposés par damiano
qu henri lopès va commenter ça il le dit
dans des parties spéciales commentaires
attaque le pion scène pour le protéger
les noirs peuvent faire trois choses
deux cavaliers ans et 6 il pourrait
proposer deux camions c6 et ceci est le
mieux selon damiano ou bien deux des six
îles ceci n'est pas aussi bon parce que
le faut et fuite reste enfermé et enfin
2 m6 et le pire donc qu'il faut
comprendre c'est que damiano lui-même
nous explique et c'est repris donc dans
ceux de ce traité ne remet au ps qui
donc avec une pierre vous faites deux
coups puisqu'on à la fois le traité de
rio ps notamment le livre 2 mais aussi
on a le plus le traité de damiano de da
en fait
donc il dit dernière c'est le pire donc
ce gambie qui est en gambie saint
sacrifice ici que font et noir vous
allez voir pourquoi où les blancs
d'ailleurs on sait pas trop qui sacrifie
koala lien ici parce que vous allez voir
ça va partir dans tous les sens dames et
ne conseille pas de le faire il dit que
c'est le pire et il va expliquer
pourquoi ce que les blancs peuvent
prendre là le cavalier le pion aux 100
voilà ils peuvent prendre le pion aux 5
avec lecavalier
pourquoi parce qu'il suit ici si les
noirs prennent 5
il ya damage cinq échecs et si les noirs
jouent g6 pour parer les chefs il ya la
même astuce qu'on a vu tout à l'heure
côté noir c'est à dire que la dame à
prendre ou cinq échecs au roi et on va
gober la torah fuite voyez donc damage
cinq échecs alors rue lopez nous dit
attends sur la cde will open et pas
damage 6 plus comédie damiano donc là on
comprend que c'est lui qui parle et
damiano aurait dit d'un mach 6 alors
alors il n'a pas dit la machine s'il a
dit la dame sur la troisième case de la
tour du roi adverse
voyez il a dit ce qu'il a dû dire
quelque chose comme ça alors c'est pas
la troisième c'est la quatrième fait une
petite erreur alors oui lopes
l'expliquent sepa damage 6 plus qu'on le
dit damiano mais cette erreur doit être
imputée à l'imprimeur ou bien la mémoire
de damiano bons commentaires naugle
lopez expliquer l'erreur qui a dans le
traité donc ici j'ai 6 alors qu'il ya
notre coût possible
g6 et ensuite il suit donc après g6 d'en
prendre cinq échecs dames e7 temps prend
la fuite
voilà gagner la tour et la damien nous
propose dame prend 1 4 échecs et
maintenant caballos est parce que le
câble est attaqué et simplement dame
prend 1,7 puis les blancs fera en sorte
d'échangé les dames puisque par ce moyen
ils sont gagnants
donc ici maintenant les blancs ont
essayé d'échanger des dames puisqu'ils
longo ils ont gobé une tour un donc
contre contre une pièce ils ont donné le
lecavalier le cavadee il a disparu
contre la tour donc sur une qualité ils
ont pris aussi le pion le pion h7 le
pion le pion et f6 n'existe plus le pion
aux 5es à sauter et donc deux pions et
une qualité donc effectivement c'est un
avantage de blanc en est alors
maintenant évidemment commentaires de
rui lopes alors il nous dit tout ceci
est la doctrine de damiano
mais avant que nous allions plus loin
avec son jeu convient de faire une
remarque sur ce qui précède notamment
il nous propose donc ici sur dame 7
d'impro ensuite il nous propose le coup
très intéressant bien entendu cavalière
6 et nous dit en passant fermer la dame
blanche
ceux-ci effectivement ça va on a
l'impression que la dame blanche ici est
enfermé à regarder la plus de cases on
peut pas prendre le cas magnitski est la
dame la dame peut pas prendre cette
piste et à la dame qui protégeait le
cavalier et puis mais le fou empêche
aussi de bouger voilà donc en pensant en
fermer la dame blanche ensuite qu'est ce
qui nous dit simplement les blancs
regard des fonds le coût des quatre et
l'agro commentaires novillo ps pour
ouvrir la voie aux phocéens on ouvre la
voie aux phocéens et on ne joue pas des
trois pour ne pas fermer celle du fou à
on joue pas des trois avec le pour ne
pas en fermer la voie du foie sont ce
qu'ils ont envie de sortir lui aussi
jour l'autre est plutôt en c4 que en
vaut deux alors pourquoi on ouvre la
voie du fou et c'est un parce qu'on a
envie de venir en 6 pour clouer le fouet
fuite comme ça on peut échanger avec la
dame et le fou on échange d'un mais fou
contre dame est fou et comme on a une
qualité de plus c'est bon pour les
blancs voilà pour ouvrir la fois où
c'est un ne joue pas des trois pour ne
pas enfermer celle du fou et fin parce
qu'il est nécessaire pour le secours de
leurs dames que les fous entre en jeu
rapidement
et de ne pas s'occuper présentement de
garder vos pions parce qu'en libérant la
dame le jeu blanc restera bien meilleur
que celui de leurs ennemis
voilà donc on veut libérer cette dame h
8 avec suffisamment davantage pour
pouvoir gagner puisque on a une qualité
de plus sans jouer rsi ou pourrait voir
le jeu blanc se comprimer le terme ce
comprimé mais en déblayant les voies la
voie aux deux fous à anjou en d4 on lit
vers la voie des deux fous dans est très
intéressant ce coût des quatre groupes à
détroit en libérant la voix de fou le
fouet fin pour le jouer en âge six
attaquants le faut et fuit de clouer et
le fouet fin pour pouvoir le fou c'est
un pardon ici et le fouet fin pour
pouvoir donner richet corps adverse donc
évidemment le fouet fin éventuellement
on pourra venir ans et quatre échecs
encadreront f7 par exemple écoutez bien
ce qu'ils disent et le fun pour pouvoir
donner chez cora dire s'il venait à
jouer avec 7 mais pas tout de suite ce
qui sera un mauvais coup mais en son
temps il nous explique pourquoi regarder
parce que si on joue tout de suite
bref cette nous montre la suite il faut
donc noter ici que vous ces cas de plus
c'est un mauvais coup car il suffit ces
quatre échecs parce que surtout ces
quatre échecs regarder des 5
et oui parce que regarder le pion aux 4
il est cloué la wii donc en fait ils
attaquent pas vraiment des cinq donc la
d5 on est protégé par le cavalier si
cécile et le fou pelé blanc prennent ces
lignes audi a1
ici en foot ronces il faut prendre des 5
alors attendez hop voilà s'il faut
prendre les 5 simplement ici cavale et
prendre des cinq car le pion au quatri
cloud et voilà une autre raison pour
laquelle il faut jouer cette des quatre
donc l'autre raison pour laquelle il
faut jouer ce coup des 4 il me dit est
de pouvoir pousser le 5 quand il
convient alors al'avantage aussi qu'on
pousse 5
on n'a pas peur de dame prend ici en
fait parce que ont joué sans doute un
coup comme le roi a des seins on laisse
même les noirs prennent un des cas
puisque ça nous permettra de sortir les
pièces d'amener la tour faire un échec
sur la colonne eux
voyez donc à la limite ça ouvre le jeu
pour les blancs à écouter bien parce que
s'il ya une anecdote très importante
dans ce passage pour pourra jouer 50 il
convient attaquant le khalife 6 tout en
restant protégé par le pion des quatre
damiano n'a touché du doigt aucun de ces
points
son début et enjoué par quelques joueurs
principalement face à ceux qui ne savent
pas beaucoup sa mère face aux débutants
cela fut même joué quelques fois face à
moi parra joueur estimé qui se faisait
appeler l muchacho des romains elle
muchachos à venir le jeune homme de rome
est lucho dès lors ma pensée au kit de
brooklyn pour bobby fischer on disait le
kit de brooklyn c'est un peu ça c'est en
italien ou en espagnol el moudja
cho'gall roma et il ya une note de bas
de page ici qui nous dit mucho donc je
nomme adolescents et qui était cet
intrigant muchacho delmas est pas clair
qui s'était soumis tchatcho puisque
cette date le nasdaq ou tricky finira
par par l'emporter face à rui lopez mais
quatorze ans plus tard il y avait que
huit ans à ce moment là donc huit ans ça
fait un peu jeune pour s'appeler
muchacho et un autre italien fameux de
l'époque paulo boy avait apparemment en
32 ans donc c'est certain
sans doute ni l'eau ni autres donc ça
devait être le joueur fameux messénie
leonardo da coutry ni paulo boys alors
ils appellent muchacho 1
gamin de 8 ans est possible qu'il se
faisait appeler al muchacho de l'oma à
rome au début du pontificat du pape pie
4 en l'an mille cinq cent soixante
ceci étant noté revenons à notre sujet
en suivant le jeu de tamié nous donc
c'est intéressant
intéressant de savoir que que ce début
donc né peut jouer uniquement par départ
des joueurs qui veulent provoquer
l'adversaire qui est plutôt des
débutants et que ça a été joué contre
lui quand même il explique à rome en
15/100 60 alors qu'il était à rome pour
l'élection du pape pie 4 alors il nous
propose aussi une variante sur 3 e set
on peut regarder ici après prise prise
d'un match 5
ici nous proposera un set voilà trois
sets
simplement on fait d'en prendre cinq
échecs 3f sept fous ces quatre échecs
des 5 alors il nous propose d'avoir
roger 6 une possibilité de rouler si ça
mais ça c'est une variante on va le voir
après bon je vous la montre quand même
tout de suite il nous propose voilà ici
roi g6 la variante elle est là sur cette
variante après on va revenir la partie
sur cette variante puisqu'on est dessus
damages cinq échecs 3,6 il simplement
des trois échecs
pourquoi des trois échecs puisque le fou
fait un échec aurons 26 ans et des coûts
connus dans ce fameux gambeat de 2,2
damiano g5 et regardez maintenant le
cours h4 très fort et si les noirs ne
joue pas donc le fameux coup des cinq
combats qu'on va voir tout de suite ils
perdront la dame il sort en maths domino
ne dit pas plus qu'ils perdront la dame
mais en fait ils expliquent que la 6e'
sa perte ou puisque là
les noirs jouent des scènes qu ici forcé
il faut absolument jouer ça attaque la
dalle et attaquent aussi le fossé 4 mai
c'est au blanc de jouer et ya quand même
a changé 5 avec échec du pur mais aussi
de la tour donc il faut sur un double
échec bouger le roi ici en g7 et la
maintenant dans le cinq échecs qui
ramassent la tourache 8 qui qui de plus
sur roy et vii permettrait fou prend des
cinq échecs or en échec double page et
d'oublier ans les noirs ici joue aucun
relief si ça ne faut pas perdre la tour
la tourache fuite et se faire mater
derrière le mieux que tu joues les noirs
c'est ce que nous dit on au ps
ici on prend m6 échec d'un point m6 d'un
problème si c'est chez croit prend et
maintenant simplement fou prendre des 5
et les blancs restent avec sept clients
contre 4 noir dans cette variante
alors on va revenir puisqu'il ya une
autre suite surtout ces quatre voies la
up
donc on revient la variante principal
roi ou 7 pouces et quatre échecs
ici on ne sait pas là je crois que c'est
encore avant
alors si vous ici un échec non c'est pas
ici qu'est ce qu'il nous propose
bah non c'est ça aussi la variante en
fait hein je crois qu'on a plus ici sur
cinq
art et 24,7 de prendre cinq ici bref
c'est dessous des 4 en fait c'est la
variante voilà d'accord c'est la
variante tourner en rond la ronde on a
on a je crois qu'on a tous vu ici alors
commentaires de rio ps ceci est la
doctrine damiano alors mais il va
enrichir en fait cette partie c'est pour
ça il va enregistrer deux parties au
chapitre suivant où il va expliquer
comment je vous le dis parce si la
doctrine de deux grammy damiano quoique
dit par d'autres mots et avec une
démonstration plus clair ici la
démonstration roux lopez est plus clair
parce que selon selon lui qu'on
m'explique damiano c'est quand même pas
pas facile avec quoi il met fin à toutes
les tous les modes de jeu et bonne
direction des partis qui commence par le
pion loin ce sont de bonnes techniques
pour diriger la partie pour enseigner à
à jouer d'une façon tant profonde que
subtile chacune
je le crois et vous le verrez vous le
comprendrez vous même
même si vous n'êtes pas un très bon
joueur donc il explique quand même ce
début est très important à est très
intéressant à analyser pour pour
enseigner voilà parce qu'il ya quand
même déçu de force est assez longue et
donc ce début est vraiment très
intéressant à étudier ce fameux gambie
de damiano pour le développement pour la
table du roi est il le dit déjà donc à
cette époque mais avant que je donne
beaucoup de façons de pouvoir diriger le
jeu en attaque un défense des deux camps
en débutant la partie par cette voie cas
comment a commencé damiano may en
démontrant dans celle-ci ce qu'il n'a
pas prévu ni consolidé donc montré plus
de choses hein que damiano je veux
traiter un peu de ces dernières manière
de diriger la partie qu'il a montré du
côté de l'attaqué et qu'en espagne on
appelle le gambit de damiano et parce
que je serai longe foulée de ce siège
chapitre à part voilà donc en fait il
vit montrera d'autres variantes dans un
chapitre à part pour justement un petit
peu enrichir ce début alors il fait
l'éloge de dalian au camp et sur ce
début il explique quand même tout c'est
sans doute ce qu'il a montré de plus de
plus de plus précis sur de la manière de
jouer contre ce contre sedan bide
voilà donc ici maintenant on va voir la
dernière partie que je voulais vous
montrer le dernier moment alors ses
ouailles à voir si spécial puisqu'on est
dans une partie avantage sur comment
chapitre 2 ans sur commande doit mener
le jeu celui qui aura à deux coups
d'avancé contre le pion le pion f
c'est à dire que les blancs ont donné le
pion f
et ils ont en échange de coups sûrs
qu'ils peuvent jouer beaucoup alors il
nous pouvons nous proposer deux
variantes avec le premier coup eux
quatre ils nous disent de ne pas jouer
les deux pions du roi et de la dame en
4d 4 car bien que ces coûts peuvent
sembler bon ils ne le sont pas il nous
explique il nous montre quand même
pourquoi voyager donc on ne fait pas que
le dire nous montre aussi voilà ils
montrent d'abord ne pas jouer ça est-ce
que ça paraît pas bon dans cette
ouverture
donc on a donné le pion f on est on est
faible sur la fameuse grande diagonale
qui fait échec et qui prend le pion
central donc ici regardez les noirs en
profite pour jouer une scène tout de
suite voilà désorganise le jeu blanc et
surtout on prend 1,5 d'un match 4 échecs
j'ai trois pour un éviter de se dérouter
d'en prendre quatre échecs et simplement
ici sagan à tour h1y conclut la moyenne
sinon que c'est très simple il nous
propose une variante ici sur damage
quatre échecs points en d2
et il nous dit simplement incident prend
1,4 et 1.4 et ainsi les noirs oran
incommoder les blancs et qui puisaient
leur ont fait bouger le roi et donc pour
ne pas se désorganiser il ne convient
pas de jouer ces deux coups pillon comme
je lui dis voilà donc les filmant les
noirs ont incommodé les blancs puisque
le roi blanc a été obligé de jouer
à noter notamment qu'il ne peut plus
sauté peu plus sauter et puis on a rendu
le pion on a rendu le camp même avec ici
avec les blancs on a donné le pion
central donc ces cépages ne sais pas ce
qu'il conseille donc il nous propose
plutôt une autre voix ici toujours en
sueur sur ce début donc on a donné le
pion bref on a deux coups on joue
d'abord 4 mais on joue plutôt qu'à l'e3
comme deuxième coup voilà dans cette
partie donc à avantage et là il nous
explique que 5
on ne prendra pas avec le cavalier par
peur de l'échec sujet dit donc là
évidemment on ne prendra pas 5 à cause
du fameux dame h4 rychen g3 d'empreintes
quatre réussites on va gober la tour
machin à noter que les le fameux chèque
dès la découverte du cas meilhon on l'a
vu tout à l'heure un marché moyennement
puisque le roi bush et sur cavaliers
prend on risque d'avoir un cavalier qui
sortira pas ici il aura du mal à sortir
on va défendre et avec les normes on va
finir par reprendre le cavalier on aura
une qualité et une qualité de plus on a
pris là on a deux pièces pour une bonne
tour pardon ce qu'ont appris la tourache
1 et on va récupérer le cavalier contre
la tour donc ici il nous propose
fu c4 c5 et maintenant c'est trois ou
très souvent joué paru lopez qu'on vous
pourrez constater le coup ces trois pour
jouer des quatre assez vite du coup que
fini doit aussi jouer
quelquefois d'ailleurs un ampli dans on
est quand même deux cents ans plus tard
un faut pas oublier mais il joue quand
même en cours toujours à l'époque et
peut-être ça vienne de cet ancien façon
de jouer c'est rester et on est resté
sur ses débuts anciens avant de changer
le fusil d'épaulé quand on s'est rendu
compte finalement que le rock changer
quand même dramatiquement la façon de
juger la position donc ici cavaliers c6
des quatre voies la normale
ça c'est un début normal on assure
protéger des cas pour on est protégé par
le cavalier le pion la dame
les noirs ont pouvoir prendre une
première fois et après la prise bien il
faut un échec pour pas perdre de temps
et simplement sur ces pièces cavalli ces
trois cavaliers et 6 à noter qu'ici on
peut par ok on peut éventuellement
sauter et si on soit avec le roi là tout
reste enfermé c'est pour ça que dans
quelques parties
on voit les blancs jouer d'abord le
retour en f1 et ensuite après le rock
saute par dessus et ils appellent ça
transposé henri lopes a donc que le rock
en dotant s'il voulait donc à l'essai 3
accueille lille 6e 5 attaques lecavalier
bien sûr car il le 4 est maintenant
d'albé 3 lord a mené 3 jeux protège la
case c3 donc en cas de prise en c3 je
reprends du pion la dame protell même
temps j'ai attaqué deux sets il nous le
dit attaquants f7 ou bien encore nous
propose aussi une autre cool le jouet
dam des trois et ainsi pour peu qu'ils
sachent jouer les blancs organiseront
bien leur jeu voilà alors il dit souvent
ça pour peu que l'on qu'ils sachent
jouer
il dit souvent ça c'est c'est un
leitmotiv cyril au ps pour peu qu'ils
savent jouer il le dit tout le long du
livre
il précise bien vous avez gagné mais
encore faut-il que vous sachiez jouer
parce qu'il faut encore jouer quoi rien
il ya encore des choses à faire pour
gagner mais il guigne bien les blancs ou
les noirs ont davantage quand il termine
ses conclusions
si l'on joue en dehors de ce qu'il est
dit ici gardez à l'esprit ces coûts à
fournir selon leur nécessité
car en les connaissant vous pourrait
bien mener votre vous voyez donc les
conseils auraient loupé ce centre est
intéressant il vous le dis tiens même si
c'est en dehors de ce qui est dit là ces
coûts sont un peu en quelque sorte des
coûts standards
voilà c'est une façon standard d'ouvrir
le jeu c'est une façon bien bien utile
bien bien réfléchi de jouer et qui
finalement se retrouve dans d'autres
dans notre début un autre début de
partie
donc il vaut mieux le garder à l'esprit
car car elles sont c'est des cons utile
voilà equity la connaître voilà donc
très intéressant même dans les parties
avantage on apprend des choses à notre
huile open voilà c'est ça qu'il faut
noter dans ce manuel est bien que la
façon de jouer est un peu différente à
cause du droit qui sautent notamment
mais essentiellement que ça il va aussi
faire quelques à nice deux parties
quand même avec le rock puisque non pas
avec le rock avec le coup la prise en
passant voilà il fait avec la prise en
passant il promeut la prise en passant
dans toutes les parties de lopez sont
avec la prise en passant mais comme en
italie à l'époque on ne joue pas avec la
prise en passant et bien il fera parfois
des chapitres pour expliquer si on joue
la mode italienne alors voilà il faut
jouer un peu différemment il montre des
variantes sans la prise en passant mais
il n'y a pas tant que ça il doit y avoir
deux ou trois chapitres où il explique
comment jouer la mode italienne sur
quelques variantes un peu un peu tendu
et voilà donc on arrive à la fin de
cette de cet aperçu voiliers de ce
manuel très riche 457 rage ce fameux
manuel de rue lopes de ségou là d'où je
vous lis la postface dernière page donc
voici enfin traduit en français
entièrement modernisé le très fameux
manuel deruy lopes des sigles a publié
en 1561 et qui contient donc l'origine
de la non moins fameuse ouverture
espagnols appelés aussi rue lopez on l'a
pas vu aujourd'hui
parce que ce serait trop long on peut
pas tout voir on a vu le gardien damiano
et en quatre livres donc le prêtre
espagnol et meilleur joueur de son temps
consolide origines fondement et pratique
du jeu d'échecs à une époque où les
règles sont encore disparate entre
l'espagne et l'italie où il se
pratiquait le plus c'était vraiment
entre l'espagne italique ont pratiqué le
plus le jeu au portugal aussi bien sûr
bon portugal et l'espagne comprend bien
que c'est quand même extrêmement proches
cette traduction et adaptation reprend
tout le contenu original ça a été
vraiment traduit à partir de l'original
à partir vraiment du texte original en
espagnol je suis je suis pas nisand et
donc j'ai fait j'ai fait une traduction
vraiment à partir de l'original j'y
tenais d'abord de toute façon je crois
qu'il ya que ça et je crois pas qu'ils
aient d'autres de toute façon d'autres
éditions où on puisse le lien tout
simplement
mais je l'aurais fait quand même de
toute façon à partir de l'original même
si ça m'était le cas voilà en
retranscrivant les parties annotations
algébrique agrémenté donc d'un nombre
considère d'échiquier qu'on vous avez vu
dans les exemples il ya beaucoup
beaucoup défi qu'est il y en a tous les
deux trois quatre ou maximum il ya
vraiment vraiment de quoi le lire sans
échiquier à côté même si ici on a mis un
échiquier on aurait presque pu s'en
passer même pour faire cette cette
présentation
voilà donc ce manuel fameux manuel de
rue lopes
enfin édité en français est vraiment
c'est une merveille
j'ai pris un très grand plaisir et aussi
j'ai eu un très grand respect en lisant
ce livre puisque on est quand même
connecté là à l'histoire la grande
histoire du jeu d'échecs est vraiment la
très grande histoire avait cru lopez et
je trouve crois quand même que c'était
un manque considérable considérable que
ce livre n'est n'est vraiment jamais
pris sa place dans les bibliothèques et
chicken française c'est à lire pour les
passionnés d'histoire aussi parce qu'il
ya quand même beaucoup de textes qui
nous ramène à l'histoire et aux règles
du jeu de l'époque donc en terme
d'histoire du jeu d'échecs
ce livre est fondamental c'est à partir
de ce livre que les traités des jeux
d'échecs du
du xviie siècle vers les années 1600
vont commencer à paraître faut savoir
que premiers livres en allemand n'a été
éditée que dans les années 1600 17 je
crois fille dort en parle dans son
introduction du de son analyse du jeu
d'échecs dans son introduction de de
l'édition de 1749 qui pendant celle de
1717 milles en parle voilà pour le
premier livre allemand et puis les
premiers livres anglais c'est pareil on
n'a pas de livres anglais en 15 100 et
quelques ou ou très très peu si vous
voulez ou c2c de l'ordre du traité de
luz et là c'est à dire ces quelques
positions éventuellement mais il pas un
traité aussi complet aussi théorique que
le bruit lopez qui a fait école et c'est
pour ça qu'on appelle ça maintenant la
partie espagnole a remis au ps c'est
qu'à partir de là toute l'espagne s'est
mis à jouer cette ouverture qui l'a
proposé et qui qui s'est trouvée analysé
enrichi et qui est parvenu jusqu'à nous
et qui encore et joué dans les
championnats du monde voilà donc merci
de m'avoir suivi sur cette émission des
gones à tv spéciale donc sorti en
octobre 2015 dessous quelques jours de
ce grand monument de l'histoire du jeu
d'échecs livre de l'invention libéral
hier du jeu d'échecs de ruines lopez
décès ghoul a traduit de l'espagnol 450
qui note de bas de page 457 pages en
tout comprendre
comportant donc quatre livres et donc je
vous le dis le sommet en lui-même il
fait pas loin de 16 pages de somer c'est
vraiment une somme considérable et qui
je crois mérite vraiment d'être lu et
étudié pour son aspect historique
fondamentale mais aussi pour comprendre
comment les règles du jeu du cheikh ont
évolué aussi et aussi pour apprendre et
bien les bases de la technique et de la
combinaison aux échecs et la base des de
la technique de la l'ouverture des
parties du jeu des pions déjà rue lopez
nous explique plein de choses comme
débutants devraient commencer à
connaître et pourquoi pas en le faisant
en même temps qu en étudiant l'histoire
du jeu faire d'une pierre deux coups ça
me paraît une excellente façon d'étudier
le jeu des rois le roi des jeux le jeu
d'échecs
merci à tous
à bientôt pour une prochaine émission
sûreté gonal tv